[Music]
and pizza party fail news that said
submitted by sexy alien alright mmm
a New York City pizza festival turned
out terrible is now under investigation
that's how they take like pizzas so
seriously out there like they have to
investigate a pizza celebration or be in
town something about the pizza I don't
know why we can't recreate the same
pizza it's just like the way they can't
recreate Mexican food out there yeah oh
yeah they can't make Mexican a Detroit
you know to keep trying yeah they keep
trying just break the Mexicans do it
like it's not trying to make you make it
sound like it's a shuttle on over yeah I
don't understand what it is the pizza
over there is like why are you so
delicious and why can't we do that here
all the New York style pizzas here in LA
they're not the same so I've heard the
word is because the dough is from the
Atlantic Ocean and like that's the [ __ ]
yeah like that location I has the right
elevation she'll [ __ ] know it's just
good I will say this though I've had
British food or whatever [ __ ] you call
it on fish and chips in London is better
he says that about UK food that it
[ __ ] sucks
is that true people from UK it suck if
you came to America and then you ate our
food and you went back and you're like
I'm gonna kill myself
oh you do there's just so used to it
like their their taste buds are used to
that flavour and just like with us like
we're used to whatever we like is like
when we went to Italy and I was tasting
the Italian pizza it was too clean for
me where I'm like we're all the
preservative American food like
regardless of what kind of ethnic food
that you're trying to make it's always
even more saltier more sweet more savory
more buttery
yeah that's the problem when Americans
go elsewhere to eat that we go hard dude
yeah it's like it's just bland to us cuz
also usually pepperonis forty pepperoni
yeah
I mean Sicily I'm like am I getting
ripped off yeah what I'm in other
countries I'm like what is this [ __ ]
you're cheating me right all I went all
over Europe a couple years ago and I met
up with with people who knew me and
Nikki from YouTube and stuff and they're
like you've got to try this beer this is
the [ __ ] the best beer like like I'm in
Copenhagen I'm in Germany like this is
the beer and I'm in London like this is
the beer [ __ ] was [ __ ] just regular
as blood wiser beer [ __ ] water
guys watered-down as hell not that good
like you're like why is it warm yeah I
know right it's not cold yes our
standards
I got cultura exactly's high school
that's to be like cold cold stuff but
what it is is it's stupid traditions
getting in the way of innovation it's
people who are like this is how beer has
been made like the beer that was made by
the farmers of our time and all this
[ __ ]
so we'll keep making it the exact same
way whereas in America we didn't have a
cultural identity with beer yeah we had
shitty ass [ __ ] Budweiser beer and
and Miller beer
although later on if they want to pay me
to say that it's not shitty I'm happy to
take no but you don't mean like it like
yeah that's why we made crack in a ball
we can try different things we can come
out with 50 different flavours exactly
because we had no cultural traditional
identity that likes cling to with all of
our might and by the way anytime that we
do that we make shitty thing cuz we just
don't evolve we don't evolve exactly I
will say though I do like the in-n-out
burger
that [ __ ] is classic burger it's good
they just make it regular it's just a
good regular burger but have you had
habit burger habits too expensive for me
that's what I think I think habit burger
is the [ __ ] I remember going to have it
and I think it was too pricey because to
me I like both but the amount was like
four dollars cheaper so I can use it yes
anyways about this New York City pizza
party fail so they're calling it the
fire festival of pizza parties or
festivals so have you guys heard of the
fire festival no huge what do you mean
no he talks about Nikki means you forget
it was like this huge festival that they
were promoting in the Bahamas where it's
gonna be luxuriously the ja Rule
festival that's what I know it is yeah
and so people show up it's like there's
nothing there's no proof oh I remember
huge like [ __ ] fail into the toggle
system anyway so now this festival here
they were claiming it to be this like
super eclectic tasting of the best pizza
in NYC and that they would have a
celebration of the dough cheese tasty
sauces and delicious topping and so once
the event went down more than 30,000
people have plan to show up but then
once people will start showing up they
found that all they got were tiny ass
little hors d'oeuvres terrible why is
there more crust than Pizza I don't know
the size of this finger where's the
pizza though like there's no toppings
it looks like trash he was boy does look
like garbage yeah i can't read' Caesar
cheese on there it is it's all cheese
but don't you think I'd rather have a
microwavable pizza than that it just
looks like a skin graft for Freddy
Krueger yeah people are paying tickets
ranging from like $22 all the way up to
$75 and so people were fuming they're
like what the [ __ ] we want a refund
I would torch that whole place down for
$75 I'm torching somebody's place down
yeah I'm spending more money to burn it
down than I did you better believe it
how much did it cost for the [ __ ]
propane is [ __ ] but who's the [ __ ] that
put this together well they don't really
mention it
they're running away well organizers and
that event the New York Attorney General
is opening an investigation if you would
have stopped I want to see that speech
he's like that pizza was [ __ ] I'm
gonna get to the bottom you know what is
that speech last time I ate pizza it's
been a minute yeah that's a lot of
people they bought they bought these
tickets to this event through like
multiple different areas and so some
people have gotten refunds for a lot of
them haven't and then so the these
festival organizers are saying that
there will be a makeup festival that
will be better but people are like [ __ ]
that we just want to bring got time for
that
can you imagine being the lady there or
the guy there who's like I thought this
pizzas pretty good what'd I miss
like they hear everyone's outraged like
all right I guess I don't really know my
pizza they'll serve their [ __ ] it's like
pure garbage and the label what's
[ __ ] wrong with it also well first of
all your [ __ ] mouth because are you
making this and you think that is good
that's insane
how did you even build the restaurant
around that [ __ ] yeah like who told you
that was good food yeah I feel like it
was a scam yeah for sure it's a scam
they probably look like Cosmo pizza and
it okay I'm gonna improvise here buy
some pizza yeah well cut it up into
small little pieces because it's and we
won't worry about plating yeah exactly
like before it opened there was a liner
on the block waiting and they just saw
like a couple of tents up and people are
like what sucks is that you could have
had a good event you would have made
more money if this was like an annual
thing that you did and did it right but
the thing is con artists or dumbasses
like they just rather take a small piece
of the pie and then run away with it
because 30,000 people showed up paid 20
to 75 bucks each you could have had
other vendors that paid you to bend
there and in like giveaway were
giveaways pizza samples or whatever to
promote their pizza restaurant man they
could have done this right and probably
made a killing
you know [ __ ] it all up I'm an
American I'm used to getting ripped off
I go to restaurants all the time i order
drinks there's no [ __ ] alcohol in the
drink
that we both know that $17 right right
it's like yeah it's like fits exactly 20
our drink $21 drinks sometimes and
there's no alcohol in it but you know
what I'm happy and fine I'm out with my
lady whatever but like see you got you
you just don't rip me off blind like
this like this is just crazy
it ripped me off smart thank you has
anyone ever been to a good food festival
before I've never heard of a good one
you know have a have like the garlic
festivals they have a lobster festival
in San Pedro I've been a little off sir
one and it [ __ ] sucks really we were
gonna go to it that's like four tents
and you got a DJ there a beer and it
[ __ ] sucks he's not sick so far so
what what else why is it so because they
only have like four tents and we got a
DJ brother that's it's just a boiled
lobster or steamed lobster is it boiled
well like it's tender it's leverage when
I can rubbery and because when I think
of a lobster festival I'm thinking like
all the lobster connoisseurs of the
world is coming to this and that it's
not like there's all these different
boots like you got your grilled you got
our garlic you got your agent you got
your you think it is an abstruse cream
that's not any market it's you on those
brochures oh [ __ ] that's the best right
so basic as [ __ ] lobster then you get on
a [ __ ] paper plate well maybe we're
just expecting too much
once again exactly probably how much did
you pay for that I don't remember
forty bucks or something like that yeah
for this pretty much the lobster price
what you're getting and then you don't
even get to sit down because there's
like a hundred people on one little
lunch table it sounds like you went to
some kids shitty birthday party dinner I
went to the Gilroy Garlic Festival is
boring all the other stuff it's like
meeting a group of people you're only
gonna find one or two people you connect
with same [ __ ] with food festivals and
one or two places you're gonna like just
stick to that and just say [ __ ]
everything else
so if the food festival cost like 50 60
bucks again and I'm not going in [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I'm gonna take that money and
buy dinner for me and my girlfriend
somewhere else in a place I like you
know I'll go to Cheesecake Factory and
I'll spend $30 more yeah
you very much yeah no that one that we
went to I don't forgot what it was
called but you remember I don't think
dessert or something that was pretty
good
that looks cool it was more cool though
it's because like all that convention
then the convention was cool they just
had a lot that wasn't just desserts
that's why I liked it as well also I got
free stuff yeah because I'm me and I'm
that guy that's really about it like
which which influencer is the fattest
that one food conventions are different
because they're like restaurants and
suppliers and all these people trying to
like sell to two other restaurants or
whatever the public right so there's all
these free samples new products whatever
when you go to festivals majority of
these people are like part-time family
like booth errs they don't even own a
restaurant they're engineers like
full-time or something and legit
restaurants don't really go in and do
these things festivals in Sacramento are
[ __ ] dope though just because it's
like culturally diverse is [ __ ] and
there's always alcohol and there's
always bands playing there's music
there's other [ __ ] to do besides just go
there and eat food so they have events
they have all this other [ __ ] that's
like places for like day care for kids
and could toss those little [ __ ] away
it's more like a fair yeah it's like a
fair so Sacramento has a bunch of that
[ __ ] every month so that's how I've used
up and then when I came to LA and I saw
the food festivals and it's just a bunch
of crappy booths with one or two good
things it's like what the [ __ ] is this
convention food row Alameda Street Fair
next to it was [ __ ] dull yeah they do
that
yeah like different types of times
events me and Nikki were in Palm Springs
and it was 117 degrees outside in the
head like a street fair and I'll just
never forget the band they were just
like crazy like they're like thank you
goodnight and they army crawled out of
there you know what my [ __ ] is farmers
markets sometimes you find really good
like stands and food and all that stuff
and you're not to really pay to get in
for most of them all farmers markets are
dope
because it doesn't cost you [ __ ] and you
just walk through and you know you could
get some baked goods you could get some
beef jerky samples yeah you could adopt
a cat while you're there and weirdest
smorgasbord of [ __ ] get dream catchers
like see a hippie selling moonstones and
ah yes some [ __ ] made out of metal for
some reason hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm gonna hug the [ __ ] out of you
with you other than that you know
there's like more videos up there bro